it's partly cloudy in cincinnati 85
degrees 10 chance of rain as the royals
get ready to play the final game of the
series with the cincinnati reds wade
miley 85 and 82 has tossed better than
1400
innings in his major league career and
now the reds will put the pressure on
salvador perez and bring the infield in
salvi was one for five with a run scored
last night
and he's after the first pitch and a
throw to the plate is wild
by about 15 feet so the royals take a
one-nothing lead
on a bad throw to home plate third
second and first and that is strike
three and a big strikeout for miley two
gone in the inning sold it like a
fastball pulled the string and had him
way out in front
3-1
bouncer novato so miley
through a bumpy inning still only gives
up the one run that's a that's a victory
yes it is
and now nikki lopez with one out batting
ninth tonight
and there's a tapper gonna be a foot
race to the bag here and why miley will
get there in time lopez can run two
quick outs and wade miley certainly
needs that kind of inning how do you get
over there running well freddie gal is
going to come in and now all of a sudden
the training staff going to come out
that's why i was wondering you know how
did miley do running over there to first
base to cover the bag knowing he injured
his groin his last start
so since they came out to look at him
whether or not it has anything to do
with
any kind of injury or tweaking anything
he throws the next five pitches
for the five out of the strike zone
and david bell now will come out to the
mound and he's gonna come out that
decision made by david bell
that was not the mandatory second visit
of the inning you're out
so
whether or not he's re-injured
his first start lasted an inning in
two-thirds
tonight on ending in two-thirds
the royals with a one-nothing lead would
begin the third inning of play salvador
perez
and salvi jumps on a hanging breaking
ball
and jolts it into deep left center field
and into the first row
for a home run
that is number four for salvy
and the royals lead 2-nothing in the
third inning
and you can add a game
to his hitting streak
now it's 10 in a row fantastic
keep on riding him jump on all aboard
mali who came on in relief in the second
inning
and monday is on to begin the fourth
and
monday takes off
that is not usually a pitch
that a runner advances on in the dirt
but we're talking about alberto mondesi
the one-two is in the dirt blocked
monday goes the throw not in time
another 3-2
a swing and a high fly ball down the
left field line it'll be deep enough the
left fielder is there makes the catch
modesty tags he comes home and the
royals take a three-nothing lead well
that's exactly what speed can do
ryan o'hearn has had a few opportunities
in this series and he's going to get
another one here with the bases loaded
one down in the fifth
that is hit in the air to deep center
field and that
is
going to be caught by senzel
so the royals will get a run
but ryan o'hearn
had a great swing he hit it over the
wall it appears and senzel brought it
back in
back through the middle monday steps on
the bag and throws to first for a double
play
and that's keller's
second tonight and he has five scoreless
innings go ahead
two out the batter will be perez perez
might be swinging the bat as well as
anybody in the lineup right now
barnhart gives him a high target but
that's out over the plate and salve
drives it into right center field and
that's going to be up against the wall
and nikki lopez comes ripping around
third base and now the royals have
scored in five of six innings
and a five-nothing lead and salvi's
driven in three
when salvador perez starts to hit balls
to right center
and to center field
he gets locked in
bottom of the seventh inning in
cincinnati the royals with a
five-nothing lead brad keller is out ian
kennedy is in keller's line very good
six innings two hits allowed no runs
three walks three strikeouts he is not
allowed a run this year 11 shutout
innings and the first pitch he throws is
whack to the seats in right field by
winker
and the reds are on the board here in
the seventh inning a five to one ball
game that'll bring up freddie galvez
with a runner at first and nobody out
and that's in the air to deep right
field and don't look now but it's a
two-run ball game
on an 0-2 pitch
hammered down the right field line
and the reds go the front six innings
with two hits and no runs they've had
three batters two hits and three runs
marlo's got to come in here i'm not sure
how loose he can be
two two from barlow
and that ball is smoked into right his
first hit is a laser to the seats
and my oh my oh my doctor
it's now five to four
well that changes everything right now
especially for josh van meter this is a
one-run ball game the entire dugout now
completely different
good for van meter he's such a good kid
trevor rosenthal is three out of three
in save opportunities
and now christian cologne
and the sliders hit on the ground franco
they're going to try and turn it and it
is in time to end the game
trevor rosenthal after all those
fastballs through a slider
and cologne rolled over on it hit a
ground ball to third
five four three
and the royals survived and mike matheny
and rosenthal both
take a big deep breath
as the royals have salvaged
the second game of the series and leave
cincinnati with a split